[Musique]
merci Muriel Jourda de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure
d'autant que la nuit a été courte
puisque évidemment on va longuement
parler du projet de loi immigration dont
vous êtes la rapporteur vous êtes élu du
morbill en membre du groupe les
républicains on parle du texte dans
quelques instants mais d'abord un mot
sur l'actualité Gérard Larché qui était
donc au au 20h de TF1 hier soir en
compagnie diel brun pivé qui ils ont dit
qu'il ne défileraient pas à côté du
rassemblement dimanche le de la marche
civique contre l'antisémitisme à
laquelle ils ont appelé est-ce que la
présence du RN est un problème pour vous
alors d'abord j'ai cru comprendre tout
de même que c'était une marche civique
comme vous l'avez indiqué de sorte que
ce ne sont pas les partis politiques qui
sont invités à cette marche et et que
enité la question de devrait pas se
poser de savoir si on défie d'à côté ou
pas du RN le RN viendra s'il estime
pouvoir manifester à cette marche
civique viendra-t-il avec ou sans
arrière-pensé je crois que c'est un peu
la question enfin euh la question du RN
elle est aussi un peu celui de de son
fondateur celui de Jean-Marie Le Pen
dont on sait que les propos étaient
assez décomplexés à l'égard de la choix
et et évidemment on ne peut que se poser
la question toujours de savoir si cette
matrice
antisémite n'a pas perduré sachant que
Jordane Bardella a indiquait qu'il
pensait que Jean-Marie Le Pen n'était
pas antisémite est-ce que du coup c'est
un problème parce que c'était plus que
des propos décomplexés il a été condamné
pour antisémitisme et vous l'avez dit
Jordan bardellaa dimanche dit je ne
crois pas que Jean-Marie Le Pen était
antisémite est-ce que dans ces
conditions ils peuvent venir à cette
marche il y a il y a une ambiguïé qui
est certaine après c'est une marche qui
est civique chacun peut y venir donc moi
ça ne me paraît pas poser de difficulté
et et je dirais qu' enfin cette question
de l'antisémitisme dans le rassemblement
national évidemment il faut se la poser
parce que l'histoire même du
rassemblement national impose de la
poser mais je suis je dirais moins
choqué par le fait que le RN veut y
aller peut-être avec des arrièrepensé
encore une fois ne nous trompons pas que
par le fait que la France insoumise ne
veuille pas y aller dire ne cachons pas
les choses entre ceux qui veulent
défiler contre l'antisémitisme et ceux
qui s'y refusent condamnons plutôt ce
qui s'y refuse ouais comment vous
l'expliquez l'absence de de la France
insoumise c'est pas uniquement la
présence du rassemblement national non
non je ne pense pas le le si si j'ai
bien vu l'actualité mais vous comprenez
que la mienne est un peu changée en ce
moment et que que je la lis peut-être un
peu en
filigran en réalité il y a un certain
nombre d'excuses qui sont données pour
ne pas manifester
contre l'antis contre l'antisémitisme
alors que les fill manifestent plus
volonté avec d'autres religions et et
notamment non pas les musulmans mais les
islamistes donc l'un explique sans doute
l'autre on va parler de votre actualité
puisque vous êtes rapporteur du projet
de loi immigration qui é examiné par le
Sénat jusque tard dans la nuit hier et
ça va continuer aujourd'hui et hier vous
êtes attaqué au sujet le plus clivant de
ce texte c'est la régul
des travailleurs dans les métiers en
tension on va voir les temps forts de la
séance avec Samia
[Musique]
dechia bonjour Samia bonjouri bonjour m
jourd bonjour et samen vous aussi vous
avez suivi jusque très tard les
discussions sur ce projet de loi
immigration et on examina hier l'article
plus controversé oui le fameux article 3
Orian qui a été supprimé hier par le
Sénat c'est l'article qui prévoyait la
régularisation
de droit pour les travailleurs en
situation irrégulière dans les métiers
en tension la droite n'en voulait pas
elle en avait fait une ligne rouge mais
ses alliés du centre eux y tenaient ils
ont donc ensemble trouvé un accord et la
première partie de cet accord c'était
donc la suppression de l'article 3 elle
a été votée hier soir à 191 voix contre
138 le résultat en fait il était connu
d'avance hein bien sûr mais ça n'a pas
empêché de très vif débats hier soir au
Sénat on regarde tout de suite un
extrait l'immigration serait
incontrôlable c'est faux aucune
statistique ne le valide vous êtes à
côté ce débat est un débat parallèle est
un un monde parallèle par rapport à la
réalité les Françaises et les Français
les
entreprises les
citoyens du sén on peut penser comme
Monsieur jado que l'immigration aucun
problème mais manifestement nous ne
vivons pas dans le même monde oui nous
voulons contrôler l'immigration pour que
les gens la dignité des personnes ce
n'est pas de leur dire venez en France
restez dans la clandestinité parce que
plus tard vous serez régularisé et çaent
l'article 3 donc était supprimé du
projet de loi immigration à la demande
de la droite mais ce cas obtenu le
centre dans cet accord c'est l'écriture
d'un nouvel article sur la la
régularisation oui pas toujours facile à
dire exite l'article 3 place à l'article
4 bis c'est le fruit de l'accord donc le
fameux accord entre la droite et le
centre il prévoit que les régularisation
dans les métiers enenstion elles vont
rester à la main des préfets comme c'est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui he en fait alors
qu'à la base de ce que proposait le
gouvernement c'était une régularisation
de droit inscrite dans la loi ce sera
donc laissé à la libre appréciation des
préfets mais les centristes y tenit les
candidats à la régularisation n'auront
plus besoin d'une promesse d'embauche de
leur employé qui pouvait être difficile
à obtenir alors voilà qui a semblé
satisfaire un peu tout le monde la
droite le centre et puis le gouvernement
Gérald d'Anin a jugé cet accord
acceptable il s'en est expliqué hier
l'important comme je me suis déjà
exprimé c'est l'esprit de compromis que
veut le gouvernement pour avoir
l'essentiel de ce qu'il demande la
première volonté du gouvernement était
de mettre fin à à
ce ce ce servage d'un temps moderne que
l'employeur pouvait s'opposer à à la
régularisation de son employé qui
pourtant demandait la régularisation
alors ça c'est ce que dit Gérald d'in
sauf que la gauche elleelle dit que
c'est faux parce que votre article 4 bis
Muriel Jourda il prévoit quand même que
le préfet peut vérifier auprès de
l'employeur la réalité et la nature du
travail du demandeur ce qui revient
quand même un peu non à laisser de
nouveau la main à l'employeur pour la
régularisation alors pas du tout la
vérification du travail c'est la
vérification de la réalité de ce dont se
prévaut le travailleur irrégulier
c'est-à-dire la vérification de la
réalisation des conditions de la
régularisation l'effectivité tout de
même d'un travail ça n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose et même pas du tout
la même chose que la régularisation
aujourd'hui qui implique que ce soit
l'employeur qui dépose une promesse
d'embauche et un contrat de travail ce
qui veut dire qu'il doit avoir une
participation effective qu'on vienne
dans l'entreprise vérifier la réalité du
travail qu'on vienent aussi vérifier les
pratiques de l'employeur ça ne met pas
l'employeur en situation de devoir
partir anticiper il est contrôlé mais il
peut pas vouir avouer qu'il emploie une
personne en situation régulière et donc
nier qu'il que qu'il a bien fait
travailler cette personne une enquête ne
ne se résume pas à interroger
l'employeur lui demandant alors Monsieur
oui ou non une enquête dans une
entreprise peut-être un peu plus poussée
tout de même que cela et sera un peu
plus poussé que cela et permettra aussi
de vérifier la situation de
l'intégralité des autres salariés
éventuel donc c'est tout à fait
l'inverse du fait qu'on demande à
l'employeur de participer on contrôle
l'employeur et ses pratiques et on
vérifie la réalité du travail on se
trouve dans une situation tout à fait
différente de celle qui existe
aujourd'hui pour la régularisation qui
existe hein l'admission exceptionnelle
au séjour elle existe depuis fort
longtemps mais elle nécessite une
démarche conjointe de l'employeur et de
la personne qui travaille en situation
irrégulière du coup il y aura pas de
régularisation automatique ce sont les
préfets qui vont décider au cas par cas
qui est régularisé ou pas comment on est
sûr qu'il y a une égalité de traitement
quel que soit euh la préfecture dans
laquelle déposer la demande de
régularisation il ne peut pas y avoir
une égalité de traitement au sens où on
l'entend en tout cas elle a été débatue
hier puisque c'est de la casuistique il
y a une multiplicité de cas différents
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour
c'est précisément son but le le le
principe que nous avons défendu nous et
que il y a des règles c'est ainsi une
politique migratoire sont des règles des
règles pour rentrer des règles pour
rester et des règles pour travailler il
faut une autorisation de travail quand
on enfrain ses règles on est en
l'irrégularité et on ne peut pas se
résigner baissant les bras en disant bah
oui ils sont dans larégularité bah tant
pis renonçons aux règles que nous avons
instauré le principe est que on
sanctionne ceux qui sont dans
l'irrégularités et on ne leur permet pas
de poursuivre leur parcours dans
lesirrégularités mais à titre
exceptionnel puisque le principe est que
l'irrégularité est sanctionner à titre
exceptionnel
l'irrégularité peut malgré tout être
régularisée c'est l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour et dans ce
cas-là effectivement on va au cas par
cas vérifier quelle est la situation
réelle de la personne au regard de
l'emploi bien sûr mais aussi et et là
nous l'avons rajouté dans le texte au
regard de son intégration alors
justement le le cas par cas c'est pas la
seule différence entre ce que proposait
le gouvernement et ce que vous avez
réécrit vous le disiez vous avez aussi
durci les conditions de régularisation
par les préfets on va y voir d'un peu
plus près ce que vous proposez les
candidats à la régularisation devront
désormais avoir travaillé 12 mois au
lieu de 8 dans la version proposée par
le gouvernement ils devront on aussi
désormais prouvé leur insertion sociale
et familiale leur respect de l'ordre
public et puis leur adhésion au mode de
vie et aux valeur de la communauté
nationale un durcissement évidemment
rejeté en bloc par la gauche on regarde
l'intervention à ce propos de la
sénatrice Mélanie Vogel peux aller faire
une recherche sur Google pour savoir ce
que c'était les valeurs et les modes de
vie de la société française al il y a
beaucoup de sources différentes c'est au
hasard fait la même chose une enquête du
C NRS de
2019 je vous en cite une partie les
Français veulent choisir leur manière de
vivre et cela se retrouve dans tous les
domaines de la vie acceptation du
divorce de l'avortement de
l'homosexualité du suicide de
l'eutanasie la progression du
libéralisme des meurs est évidente alors
moi je veux bien mais je m'inquiète pour
vous je m'inquiète pour vous alors
comment on fait concrètement Murel
jourin pour s'assurer d'une adhésion à
un mode de vie français c'est quand même
un critère qui peut sembler très
subjectif c'est un critère qui peut
sembler très subjectif mais je pense qu'
est assez bien compris par no
compatriotes nous avons et d'ailleurs ça
a été cité notamment par mes collègues
une de nos collègues du groupe
socialiste à propos de naturalisation le
débat était autre elle nous citait
l'exemple d'une jeune fille qui pourrait
être dans une famille dans laquelle elle
lui serait interdit de manifester son
consentement pour devenir française
alors que elle n'est pas née française
et ses parents sont de nationalité
étrangèr ben je pense que tout le monde
aura compris qu'il y a un certains type
de famille dans lesquels les femmes ne
sont pas traitées à égalité avec les
hommes et les femmes restent à la maison
ça nous a été dit sans sourciller par
nos collègues du groupe de gauche euh et
cela bah ça n'est pas un mode de vie
tout à fait à la française me
semble-t-il où les femmes sont à égalité
avec les hommes et quand on a des
familles dans lesquelles ça n'est pas
réel on ne peut pas avoir une
intégration mais alors on on refuse la
régularisation à qui dans ce cas de
figure très précis à l'homme ou à la
femme de la famille on refuse la
régularisation la personne qui la
demande et si c'est l'homme et bien ça
sera l'homme qui maltraite ainsi les
femmes de sa famille je veux dire à un
moment il faut être cohérent dans ce
qu'on fait nous nous n'avons pas dit que
l'immigration devait être inexistante
nous avons simplement dit qu'elle devait
être contrôlée et limitée parceil a un
constat que nousons il un constat que
moi je fais depuis ça fait 4 ans que je
rapporte le budget de l'immigration avec
mon corrapporteur Monsieur B carer
François Noel buffet président de la
commission des lois le faisait avant moi
la réalité c'est que quel que soit les
sommes d'argent qu'on peut
mettre la masse qu'on ne contrôle pas
d'immigration qui arrive
elle ne permet ni d'accueillir ni
d'intégrer ni même de faire respecter la
loi parce que les gens qui sont Sion
régulière on arrive même plus à leur
dire vous n'êtes pas dans les règles
vous ne devez pas rester sur le
territoire qui la moindre des choses on
ne peut tout de même pas nous reprocher
de vous appliquer la loi que nous avons
voté donc il est évident qu'à un moment
il va falloir contrôler c'est ce
contrôle que nous voulons et ce contrôle
il doit permettre l'intégration on ne va
pas garder sur notre territoire des gens
qui sont irréguliers et qui ne sont même
pas intégrés au mode de vie français et
il y en a enfin on va pas se cacherè son
petit doigt il y en a l'égalité
hommes-femmes n'est pas très acceptable
dans certains milieux et souvent lié à
la religion la laïcité n'est pas
acceptée dans certains milieux et
souvent aussi il y a à la religion par
définition la laïcité il y a région
quand vous vivez quand vous venez d'un
pays dans
lequel le Coran est la loi personnelle
la loi religieuse évidemment mais aussi
la loi civile la loi pénale et c'est le
cas c'est le cas moi j'ai suivi une
conférence sur la finance islamique
parce que c'est aussi le Coran qui dit
quel est le droit bancaire en France le
droit bancaire n'est pas calqué sur les
quatre évangiles je veux dire on a une
religion qui par nature a vocation à
régir tous les pans de la vie c'est
ainsi jeque pas c'est uneé je dis
simplement que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour les gens qui vivent dans
cette religion de vivre et d'accepter la
notion de laïcité en tout cas ça demande
un effort extrêmement élevé sur cet
article 3 que vous vouliez supprimer
pour éviter un appel d'air c'est ce que
vous disiez vous avez entendu Yannick
jade en séance qui dit que vous vivez
dans un monde parallèle et qu'aucune
statistique ne prouve qu'il y aurait un
appel d'air qu'est-ce que vous dites de
ça je n'ai pas souvenir qu'on a parlé
d'un appel d'air après moi je je n'ai je
n'ai jamais pris cet article y compris
sur votre plateau sous la forme de
l'appel d'air ce qui m'a toujours
dérangé dans l'article 3 et ce qui était
notre vraie ligne rouge c'est c'est que
on faisait créer à une situation de
fraude on permettait à une situation de
fraude continue puisque ce qu'on disait
c'est vous si vous justifiez que vous
avez été en irrégularité suffisamment
longtemps vous aurez automatiquement un
titre de séjour c'est-à-dire voilà si on
fraude assez longtemps et assez
habilement ça va être créateur de droit
il y a principe de droit qui est assez
simple et que tout le monde peut
comprendre la fraude corromp tout
c'està-dire que la fraude ne peut pas
être créatrice de droit là on inversait
ce principe d'une façon assez
scandaleuse on sortait du cas par cas
c'est-à-dire qu' ça entraîné une
régularisation massive donc très
honnêtement personne ne savait dire quel
était le volume de la régularisation et
là où ça peut être un appel d'air alors
ce qui est contesté par le ministre qui
nous dit attendez ce dispositif est
limité dans le temps c'est que
aujourd'hui il y a quand même des filièr
qui se crée et et on peut parfaitement
créer toute pièce et de façon mensongère
un dossier qui est est destiné à
démontrer qu'on est depuis tant de temps
sur le territoire et qu'on est
finalement dans les conditions de
régularisation % des employeurs sont des
étrangers les filières on les voit les
employeurs près de 50 % des employeurs
de clandestins sont des étrangers
eux-mêmes enfin ne soyons pas naïfs les
filières peuvent se mettre en place pour
permettre la régularisation mais même
avec votre article alors certes c'est du
cas par cas mais il y a quand même des
gens arrivés en situation irrégulière
qui finiront par obtenir un titre de
séjour c'est déjà le cas mais encore une
fois nous ne défendons pas la l'absence
de régularisation ce serait ce serait je
crois assez peu réaliste et et parfois
bien sûr enfin la régularisation met un
peu d'humanité là où les règles sont
sèches et il est nécessaire d'avoir
cette soupape mais c'est une soupape ça
n'est pas un principe et dans le système
qui existe aujourd'hui he l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour qui est à la
main du préfet le préfet garde la main
ça ne sont plus aujourd'hui nous
passions aux filières de passeur le soin
de contrôler la politique migratoire de
la France il y a quand même quelque
chose qui n'a pas été beaucoup évoqué
hier en séance c'est la le délai
d'attente qui est très long dans les
préfectures he pour les personnes qui
demandent une régularisation auprès des
préfets là vous avez augmenté
considérablement la liste de critères
donc ça peut prendre encore plus de
temps or votre texte il ne prévoit pas
de moyens supplémentaires dans les
préfectures est-ce que vous n'allez pas
créer une embolie encore plus importante
dans les services des préfectures alors
notre texte n'est pas une projet de loi
de finance donc nous ne pouvons pas
créer des moyens dans la mesure où le
texte serait voté dans les deux chambres
ce qui reste à
démontrer il appartiendra au
gouvernement de créer les moyens à
hauteur de la politique qui est mise en
œuvre donc ça n'est pas dans un texte
tel que celui que nous avons voté que
nous pouvons créer des moyens mais bien
sûr qu'il faudra des moyens à la hauteur
de de de la tâche mais je vous dirais
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez bienentô avoir
l'occasion régulariser tout le monde
n'aurait pas demandé moins de
moyens on va on va parler de la suite du
texte mais un mot sur un autre article
parce qu'il y avait l'article 3 mais il
y avait aussi l'article 4 qui posait
problème oui he c'est c'est l'article
qui proposait d'autoriser certains
demandeurs d'asile à pouvoir travailler
dès le dépôt de leur demande
actuellement ils doivent attendre 6 mois
et ils touchent en attendant une
allocation de 6,80 € par jour pour une
personne seule ce que proposait le texte
du Gouvernement c'était de supprimer ce
délai he pour les demandeurs d'asile qui
bénéficient d'une haute protection ceux
qui viennent par exemple d'Afghanistan
et dont on est à peu près sûr qu'ils
vont l'obtenir cette demande d'asile
mais là encore la droite étit contre
elle a donc fait supprimer cet article
ce qui a encore une fois prop provoqué
l'indignation de la gauche regardez
l'intervention de Yan
brossa la question est assez simple de
savoir si on préfère que les gens vivent
de leur travail ou si on préfère que les
gens vivent des revenus de l'assistance
et je suis quand même un peu étonné de
voir les les sénateurs la droite de cet
hémicycle nous expliquer qu'il préfère
que les gens vivent de l'assistance
plutôt que du travail qu'est-ce que vous
répondis à l'étonnement de Dian brossa
mur J il aura d'autres étonnements sans
doute mais nous n'avons pas envisagé la
questions sous sé d'cle évidemment que
nous avons toujours préféré que les gens
vivent de leur travail que de
l'assistance la question est de est de
savoir que
effectivement nous voulons lutter contre
le fait de dev voir régulariser des gens
et de devoir admis devant la politique
du fait accompli le travail euh c'est un
des motifs de régularisation les plus
importants alors nous ne souhaitons pas
nous-mêm créer des des motifs dans
lesquels les gens ne bénéficieraient
d'aucune protection se trouveraiit donc
en situation irrégulière mais
arriveraiit à se faire régularisé par le
travail ce qu'il faut arriver à faire et
les délais commencent à être corrects
c'est de pouvoir instruire très
rapidement les demandes pendant ce
temps-là d'ailleurs c'est la directive
européenne je ve dire nous sommes un des
rares pays à solliciter est ce que le
demandeur d'asile travaille d dès le
premier
jour la plupart du temps le délai de 9
mois c'est le délai maximum nous
l'avions ramené quand je dis nous pas
tout à fait la droite mais il avait été
ramené à 6 mois la réalité c'est qu'il
ne faut pas créer de situations où euh
ce prévalent d'une situation de travail
et bien des gens qui n'auraient aucun
titre à rester sur le territoire
arriveraient tout de même à demander le
régularisation le le le premier souhait
que nous avons eu dans ce texte c'est
quand même de maîtriser l'immigration et
pas de créer des situations où nous
serions en en situation de devoir
régulariser ou de pouvoir régulariser
donc not logique elle est celle-là
évidemment que personne ne souhaite en
tout cas nous ne le souhaitons pas que
ça soit l'Assistance publique qui qui
pie au fruit du travail on va parler de
la suite du texte puisque il va aller à
l'Assemblée en décembre et puis après
vous allez vous mettre autour de la
table avec les députés sauf que Sacha
aoulier le président de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale dit ce
matin dans le figarou qui rétablira le
texte ambitieux de l'exécutif donc
l'article 3 qu'est-ce que vous dites de
ça et est-ce qu'un compromis sera
possible du coup je dis d'abord c'est
assez inélégant avant même que le texte
soit voté et je crois que l'interview
était même donné avant que nous ayons
voté l'article 3 que de dire que tout
sera défait après le jeu des
institutions se fera c'est-à-dire que un
texte sortira d'ici ce qui est plutôt
une bonne chose ce texte sortira il ira
l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale fera ce qu'elle a à faire
monsieur Houlier pense qu'il va pouvoir
rétablir le texte qu'il souhaite parce
que j'observais quand même c'est que la
majorité est relative et qu'elle est
traversé de mouvements politiques divers
et qui ne disent pas tous la même chose
y compris au sein du gouvernement donc
nous verrons quelle est la façon dont ce
texte sera traité nous verrons s'il
passe 1493 au quel cas il n'y aura pas
de CMP il n'y aura pas de commission
mixte paritaire si le 493 est mise en
œuvre pour vous il est pas exclu malgré
l'accord au Sénat ce 493 moi ce n'est
pas à moi d'en décider vous savez que
nous ne connaissons même pas le principe
du 493 ici donc bon ça reste mystérieux
pour nous encore mais beaucoup plus
sérieusement c'est le gouvernement qui
décidera de ce qu'il fait et c'est le
gouvernement qu' décidera au vu des
circonstances qui lui seront opposé et
de la majorité qu'il pourra ou pas
dégager il ne l'a pas à l'Assemblée
nationale donc ça c'est un sujet qui
dépasse très largement le Sénat nous
verrons ensuite si nous allons vers une
commission mixte
paritaire il y a évidemment des choses
que nous n'admettrons pas
lesquels
d'abord l'article 3 et d'autres oh bien
sûr il y en aura d'autres la MU et la mu
me paraissent la me et la Muu me
paraissent un sujet sur lequel nous
pourrons facilement être en désaccord
merci Samia à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure pour parler de la marche contre
l'antisémitisme ce sera à suivre dans le
club pour terminer on va aller voir
l'actualité dans votre région bretonne
on va à Rennes retrouver Stéphane bet
bonjour Stéphane merci d'être avec nous
directeur de l'information de tven
Stéphane Stéphane voulaz revenir
évidemment sur les tempêtes qui ont
touché ces derniers jours la région
Bretagne et le morbillant qui a été l'un
des premiers départements touchés oui
madame la sénatrice a suivi avec
beaucoup d'attention ce qui s'est passé
avec vraiment de de des vents
incroyables dans cette nuit du 1er au 2
novembre dernier et ça c'est suivi
encore pendant plusieurs jours les
dégâts ont été très très importants on
pense aux coupures d'électricité 33000
foyers sont encore privés sur l'ensemble
de la Bretagne 4000 uniquement dans le
le morbillan mais il y a deux chiffres
que l'on peut donner dans ce très beau
département de cette Bretagne Sud il y a
eu quand même pratiquement euh 200
arbres retrouvés sur sur les routes il y
a eu également énormément de toitures
endommagées et puis l'activité agricole
a payé un très lourd tribut donc
vraiment il faut quand même dire que
vous voyez 12200 arbres dans le
morbillant ont été couchés et on pense à
cet arbre mythique de la forêt de
brosséiand le le Pontus qui a été lui
aussi complètement couché par cette
terrible tempête hier la région Bretagne
a donné une aide d'urgence euh d'un
million d'euros madame la sénatrice
est-ce qu'il est temps aujourd'hui pour
l'État les banques et les assurances
d'enclencher aussi ce mouvement pour
aider principalement toutes les
activités agricole maréchair à
repartir alors bonjour monsieur euh
effectivement euh il y a une difficulté
majeure pour les les activités agricoles
euh suite à cette tempête l'état de
catastrophe naturelle peut permettre
d'indemniser notamment les entreprises
et j'entendais tout à l'heure au sein
même de cette émission le ministre de
l'Intérieur indiqué que l'État prendrait
sa part dans dans l'indemnisation de
ceux qui sont victimes des des éléments
naturels dont bien sûr les agriculteurs
dont on sait qu'ils ont toujours été
très météodépendants mais là c'est
effectivement assez dramatique ce qui
s'est passé donc bien sûr il faudra
venir au secours dans le cadre d'un
système d'assurance dans le cadre d'un
système d'assurance à ceux qui ont qui
ont subi cette cette tempête d'une façon
incroyablement dramatique pour
l'activité professionnelle Stéphane un
dernier mot mais très rapidement
oui un dernier mot le morbillan aussi
est assujetti un peu aux vagues
submersion on sait que depuis très très
depuis de très nombreuses années cette
façade atlantique souffre là aussi il y
a peut-être vraiment de de fortes
mesures à faire pour préserver ce ce
littoral je crois que malheureusement
nous avons un peu manqué de de mettre en
œuvre ces mesures il fut un temps où
nous n'aurions pas dû construire un
temps où c'était d'ailleurs l'État qui
délivrait les permis de construire où
nous avons construit en des lieux dont
chacun savait qu'ils étaient
submersibles quand je dis chacun c'était
les ancien depuis toujours si je puis me
permettre et et le fait d'avoir d'avoir
construit crée une vraie difficulté
alors il y a des plans qui se mettent en
place les plans de sumersion existe les
plans de prévention des
inondations les populations prennent ça
avec une certaine philosophie je vous
dirais et il y a quelques années après
après la tempête de 2018 moi j'habite à
proximité d'une presquî j'ai constaté
que le prix des maisons de baissait pas
donc on a une situation dont on sait
qu'elle est potentiellement dangereuse
qui n'a pas été quand même complètement
intégrée par la population qu'il a été
par les élus locaux puisque ces plans se
mettent en place mais certains ont admis
que parfois les presquîes se
transformeraient en île et et que nous
nous trouverions dans cette situation
merci Stéphane benier merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous depuis la Bretagne
merci Muriel
et on suivra bien sûr toute la journée
la suite de l'examen de ce projet de
immigration dont vous êtes la rapporteur
merci d'avoir été sur notre plateau